hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel where right now or maybe in a
few minutes I don't know depends if I'm
long or not the inside Xbox that is
going to be talking all about the Xbox
series X and showing the first Xbox
Series X gameplay that we've seen as
part of a package Nintendo direct style
conference will have just ended or is
about to end I have not seen it
naturally what you're about to watch is
me going over a document that Xbox
actually sent me earlier in the week
that is a recap of everything that was
shown in this conference so I cannot
speak to the way these games look but I
did want to talk about a I really like
that Xbox is going ahead with basically
what they said to me was inside Xbox
will kick off Xbox 2020 a way to engage
Kinect and celebrate with a global
community about what is in store for the
next generation of gaming each month
will bring something different but will
feature our biggest news about Xbox
Series X Xbox game studios Xbox game
pause and Project X cloud I think that's
really cool I'm a really big fan of
Nintendo Direct and I think considering
the current landscape well you know III
was cancelled it makes a lot of sense
for Xbox to go ahead with this being
monthly I didn't expect but also very
unboard with that it means just like
regular updates and sort of an expansion
on what inside Xbox has already been
however based on this list of games that
I've been sent I don't feel like this
first look at Xbox Series X gameplay is
quite what it was hyped up to be or
perhaps what I hyped it up to be I don't
know if if Microsoft did that or I did
that to myself but I was expecting a
little bit more from the list of games
that we got obviously their crowning
jewel is Assassin's Creed Valhalla which
this document describes as in Assassin's
Creed Valhalla become evil eye ball a
legendary Viking Rado on a quest for
glory explore dynamic and beautiful
open-world set against the brutal
backdrop of England's Dark Ages raid
your enemies grow settlement and build
your political power in the quest to
earn a place among the gods in Valhalla
I don't have any beef with the
Assassin's Creed itself
I loved origins didn't finish Odyssey
but did really like it and you know have
well
you know had a complicated relationship
with Assassin's Creed but overall
despite it departing from what the
series originally was and to and
Brotherhood awfully my favorites I'm on
board with with Valhalla and the
direction is taken but I guess from this
xbox conference I really wanted to see
the leading game the an Xbox exclusive
this video is going to age really poorly
if it turns out that they didn't
disclose some major game like perfect
dark or a new fable or maybe an xbox
exclusive dubs point itself somehow
Ubisoft would not do that but somehow I
don't think they're going to do that
though but I feel like there's a long
list of things that Xbox doing really
right game poss is one of those things
this inside Xbox rollout is one of those
things but we need exclusives for sure
there are a lot of services that Xbox
have that I really like like play
anywhere and cross player both awesome
things for everyone you might say well
you know the fact that I can get all
these games on PC prevents me from
wanting an Xbox that doesn't matter if
you have a PC it's good for you if you
have an Xbox it's good for you so I
don't feel like you not wanting an Xbox
by virtue of something that doesn't make
you have to buy expensive hardware just
to get access to games it's not a
negative for anyone if it's ever going
to be a negative for someone it would be
for the company that is trying to sell
consoles but if they're the ones pushing
this agenda I am happy to take it I feel
like as a game as we should all be
stucked about it so they have a lot of
what I call pro-consumer strategies and
ideas but I don't feel like they have
the big blockbuster exclusives that I
want to see them making because damn you
think about the start of the 360 era
Mass Effect wasn't exclusive Dead Rising
Bioshock obviously gears as halo was
banging back again back in the day still
very hopeful about the new halo but we
didn't see anything about it so we go to
size of screen Valhalla you also get a
game called bright memory infinite from
play ISM so if you didn't already know
the original bright memory came out
March 25th out of early access and is
stunning and awesome I'm supposedly made
by just one guy which is crazy crazy
crazy cool but bright memory infinite is
basically like a reboot of soul
it's just it's a scale-up new edition of
bright memory which is instead of
issuing a plan episodic trilogy which is
what the developer was originally
planning to do by memory infinite is an
all-new lightning-fast fusion of the FPS
and action genres created by FY QD
Studio combine a wide variety of skills
and abilities to unleash dazzling combo
attacks it's set in a sprawling
futuristic metropolis in the year 2036 a
strange phenomenon for which scientists
can find no explanation has occurred in
the skies around the world the
supernatural science research
organization s oh he sent agents out to
various regions to investigate this
phenomenon it is soon discovered that
these strange occurrences are connected
to an archaic mystery as and as of yet
unknown history of to elves about to
come to life
next up we have Cole of the sea from
rural Fury it's a first-person adventure
puzzle game set in the 1930s it tells
the story of Noah a woman on the trail
of home missing husband's expedition the
search takes place on a strange but
beautiful island in the South Pacific
filled with secrets waiting to be
unearthed it is an otherworldly tale of
mystery adventure and self-discovery I
also feel like I will probably really
like this call of the sea sounds like
sort of a mix between them the witness
with maybe some of return to the Oberon
with maybe even Samia sma'da if you know
of any of those games they're all cool
and that's kind of the vibe that I get
from that descriptive but it's still not
not a big eye P not a big system sellout
next up is chorus from Deep Silver it is
described as a massive single-player
experience that tells a mature and Dok
tale of redemption take control of Nara
an ace pilot with a haunted past and
forsaken her sentient Starfighter as
they embark on a personal redemptive
journey to challenge a relentless fellow
and take down the dark coat that made
her it is the true evolution of space
combat shooter I mean it is worth noting
that these are all first-person I I mean
a single player I believe considering
the amount of games as service type
things we've seen out of Xbox Studios
I'm definitely on board with that I love
me some single-player then we have dart
5 from Codemasters dot is always good
that continues to be good it's done you
know what it is probably if you don't
you probably aren't interested in it
Madden NFL 21 same thing and we have
scarlet Nexus from Ben
namco take on the role of you ito
sumeragi and you recruit to the OSF
aiming to become an elite psionic like
the one who saved him as a child
armed with the talent in psychokinesis
explore the futuristic city of new
Homolka and uncover the mysteries of
brain Punk future caught between
technology and psychic abilities in
scarlet Nexus also super cool a lot of
games recently I don't know if you guys
would have seen the gameplay that I
posted up last night everyone's just
getting on that cyberpunk train right
now definitely like gaming trends the
sort of wave like TV does it really
aggressively to is like vampires and
then it's zombies and then it's whatever
else and we have scorn which this one
might be the one that I'm the most
interested in scorn is an atmospheric
first person horror adventure game set a
nightmarish universe of odd forms and
somber tapestry it is designed around
the idea of being thrown into the world
isolated and lost inside this dreamlike
world you will explore different
interconnected regions of nonlinear
fashion in a nonlinear fashion the
unsettling environments in is a
character itself I hate that I've
probably done that as a reviewer at some
point I'm sure I did that in an article
at IGN at some point I think I might've
done it for sanskrit origins when i
reviewed that but describing
environments is a character themselves
it doesn't mean anything it just doesn't
mean anything if you've played it you
would understand it but as text from a
PR person it means nothing I'm sorry to
continue every location contains its own
theme puzzles and characters that are
integral in creating a cohesive whoa
throughout the game you will open up new
areas acquire different skill sets
weapons various items and try to
comprehend the sites presented to you
I'm into this because I love horror so
the more horror you make I'm very on
board scorn looks very sci-fi it does
say inventory and ammo management is
defined and limited a place of being
role in keeping the player and even
greatest state of awareness throughout
the whole game players will have to
think about when to fight and when to
take cover and how their actions affect
the world around them different
playstyles will be needed to advance I
do love me some inventory management in
my survival horror games that's for sure
next we have second extinction from
systemic reactions second extinction is
an intense three player cooperative
shooter this is also a thing that I'm
seeing more and more of where your goal
is
wipe out the mutated dinosaurs that have
taken over the planet teamwork is vital
as you adopt the role of one of the
survivors using a unique combination of
weapons abilities and skills to take on
the vast number of enemies right through
a Maelstrom oh sorry fight through a
mouse from a bullets bombs teeth claws
and Goa it's up to you to reclaim uh can
I just pretend that that's brute force
next up we have the ascent from neon
giant and curved digital is a solo and
co-op action RPG set in a cyberpunk
world the mega corporation that owns you
and everyone the ascent group has just
collapsed confusion and chaos and shoe
security and order earned disarray and
without protection everyone's left to
fend for themselves stop gangs and
hostile corporate corporations from
taking over and discover what really
happened in this explosive sci-fi
shooter neon giant is a small team of
experienced games industry veterans
their swedish team that's cool they're
hiring for a technical director
apparently there you go the next one is
by bloobity who i love they made Blair
which which I wasn't as hot on but also
lay as a feel one and to which I love
the next game is called the medium it's
a next-gen psychological horror game
from Gluba team which checks out we have
heard a little bit about medium before
now it's it is supposedly the biggest
project Blubaugh has ever done we've
only had vague details previously but um
yeah it did already know that it was
going to be a next-gen game likely
available for PlayStation 5 and Xbox
Series X I think they're also working on
a new game set in the absorbe observer
universe but this is certainly the most
that we will have heard about about
media my god I'm gonna watch that game
play for sure you play as Mary Ann a
medium living in to Walt's a real world
and the spirit one haunted by a vision
of a child's motor you travel to an
abandoned hotel resort which many years
ago became the stage of an unthinkable
tragedy there you begin your search for
difficult answers definitely played
games that sound like this before but
but my head just goes to this is
probably going to be a lot like layers
of fear where if you haven't played
layers of fear it's a lot about like
environments constantly shifting around
you and you have very limited sense of
safety because you can turn around in a
hallway and everything behind you can be
completely different I imagine they'll
probably go with that Blair Witch did
some of that too so maybe the medium is
a little more story focused or story
focused in a different
while is fear his story focus but in a
very hot house kind of way Blair which
is much more direct but yeah happy to
have more games from them no matter what
and we have vampire the masquerade
bloodlines too from Paradox Interactive
people really like vampire the
masquerade that's a win for sure
cool and Yakuza is the last one yahooza
like a dragon obviously from Sega this I
didn't know existed at all just
announced today Yakuza like a dragon an
explosive new entry point in the
acclaimed Yakuza series will be
releasing as a launch title on Xbox
series X we were also excited to
announce that Yahoo is out like a dragon
will support Xbox series acts smart
deliberately immediately on release that
means that players who purchased the
Xbox one version of y'all crystal like a
dragon will be entitled to a free
upgrade on the Xbox Series X version
most of these games actually have that
smart delivery vampire the masquerade
does the ascent does second extinction
does Scarlett Nexus does a chorus call
of the sea and Assassin's Creed Valhalla
all do which is very very cool that's
something that we needed to hear about
and I'm glad that we did it also has
cross save functionality between Xbox
one and Xbox Series X so no matter when
players decide to upgrade they never
have to start over from rock-bottom very
glad that we have this going into next
gen that rules and that is it for me
today everyone it is very hot in here
basically like there are definitely some
games that I'm really impressed by here
some stuff that I really like I guess it
just wasn't what I was expecting from
this conference in that I expected I
expected an Xbox Studios exclusive game
something to have is there like
blockbuster title because I don't know
what that is for them going forward just
yet not that I know what that is for
PlayStation either I don't know what
anyone's launched you know exclusives or
first party games is supposed to be at
this stage but hey maybe it is on me for
making an assumption there that we would
get something like that when they didn't
really say that we would definitely
think smart delivery is awesome props to
them for that for sure
alright everyone I will see you guys
next time